busy summer ahead infrastructure
election reform
what does the press get wrong when
covering
biden's agenda five months in do you
feel you've made any progress with that
defeating the lies
you have a daughter going into
kindergarten i have a daughter going
into pre-k
and i think to myself what what kind of
country is this going to be
when they are our age do you do you fear
that
given the craziness we're seeing from
the gop oh just
ask her to the prom popping fresh
yes all right here we are
welcome back i hope you had a great
weekend
we know obviously that cat did
[Laughter]
she'll never learn poor lisa booth
doesn't know when to put the bottle down
these are our role models
so you ever write to your congressman or
senator
most of them read at a sixth grade level
so do it in crayon
but chances are all you're gonna get
back are form letters sent out by a
staffer
still i contact my local representative
a lot i keep sending them sketches of
cat's husband
still on the loose but today as a world
famous celebrity
i can get politicians to listen to me
when you can't
vincent del castillo is a professor of
criminal justice at john jay college of
criminal justice
redundant for the past 30 years served
27 years in the nyc
transit police department the last three
as department chief
this guy knows his stuff which is why
you never see him on tv he wrote to
senator tim scott about police reform
all he got back was a form letter
so i decided it's my job to amplify
vincent's sensible
solutions and none of them factor into
race
which means cnn we'll call them racists
so first let's begin with reality
like the guy with the broom at the
circus who goes where the elephants are
police go to where the crime is that's
high crime areas where decent
people of color live but also riffraff
yeah cops protecting people of color it
doesn't get any more racist than that
and so you have high crime areas now add
activity quotas
where police departments must issue a
minimum number of summonses
or make arrests over a week or a month
the problem
cops fill their quotas with minor drug
offenses prostitution
and traffic violations or what michael
loftus calls
tuesday
did you know that most negative contacts
between cops and the public
are in traffic stops and because police
are in the minority concentrated
areas the perception is that blacks are
being hassled over minor violations
and it's a fair point do you think any
cop wanted to wrestle eric garner
over selling loose cigarettes hell no if
they didn't overtax cigarettes to
control behavior there'd be no reason to
sell loose ones in the first place
but that's another gripe for another day
garner died over a loose cigarette
in george floyd's case it began with a
fake 20 bill
small things lead to huge tragedies so
what's the solution
well first get rid of activity quotas
which would stop forcing cops to chase
minor violations
besides no one ever watches a cop show
where the guy keeps arresting people for
ripping tags off mattresses
casio when he was chief got rid of
activity quotas allowing cops to spend
more time on patrol and make more
arrests for stuff like robberies
which sounds like a better deterrent
than aoc's getting rid of jails
he also wants to remove the burden of
traffic stops off cops
and put it on tech i know we hate red
light and speed
limit cameras but chances are you're
already on camera a lot these days
especially if you rented my house on
airbnb
and you thought that head and shoulders
bottle was empty
but machines make objective decisions a
camera won't care if you unbutton the
top button of your shirt
unless of course it's operated by brian
kilmeade that freak
this one step reduces negative
interactions with the public
which is also what's happening to don
lemon at the 11 p.m slot
[Laughter]
his ratings are going down do i have to
explain these media jokes to you people
traffic warnings also instead of tickets
will allow
cops more discretion and letting someone
off with a warning
always creates goodwill in the community
finally and this is for me we need to
end
the drug war we lost it a century ago so
let's pick up our hash pipes and go home
they can't even keep drugs out of the
prisons full of people in jail for drug
crimes
and as a consequence of closing
institutions we still have nuts
on the street and i'm just talking about
the mayor
[Laughter]
and we can still get any drug we want on
the street but it's poorly dosed so you
have thousands and thousands of deaths
per year
thank you china from street fentanyl so
my solution
well sitting at home i experimented with
legal substances
until i was out of my tree but i was
home
in the safety and security of an
apartment where my stupidity hurts no
one
except people who might text about my
x-ray vision
but i have what i call oblivion
privilege i can seek any
oblivion i want and not be arrested
because i'm inside and not out
but if i had been on the street and an
officer had told me to put my hands up
or
lie flat on the ground i would have been
non-compliant
because standing there in my state i
would have thought
how is this giant blue plant talking
[Laughter]
fact is people want their oblivion but
there's no way nowhere for them to go
after they get it which is why you see
them on the street or in the starbucks
bathroom
i'm lucky and industrious enough to have
my own fun without bothering others
neighbors be damned just like you having
your martini watching the five
not everyone has that luxury and it's
something to think about as others
prefer to change the subject
and call you racist
welcome tonight's guest
well the average blood alcohol level of
the panel just went up
republican strategist and fox news
contributor lisa booth
there you go she's written as many
speeches as
joe biden's plagiarize them for former
deputy national security
advisor kate d mcfarland
[Music]
he has comedy audiences on their feet
heading for the exits
theloftusparty.com editor chief michael
loftus
she looks like she's 12 yet she
complains like she's 85.
fox news contributor cat tim
so uh uh lisa how was your weekend
it was great i mean you go to one club
on one sunday and you have an
intervention on a live television show
so
you know you never went to bed this
weekend did you you just came straight
from the club how do you do that
that's how rumors you should have get
started
twitter messages and uh instagram was
hilarious
so what do you make of these reforms
that i have discussed here uh do you
agree wholeheartedly with all of them
because i think you should given the
wild partying ways in your private life
i think what you put out was smart but
what i have a problem
now with the public debate we're having
about police reform
is it's based off of a bunch of lies and
it's based on the left and the media's
lies and it's one of the deadliest lies
that's ever been told i mean you look at
uh last year alone it's the highest of
homicide records
highest annual increase in homicide
records in history you go back and you
look at
1021 people were killed by the police
in 2020 5.3 percent were unarmed
over 60 percent had guns another 17 had
a knife so i mean the entire narrative
that we're having in the country right
now
is complete bs and so that's the problem
i have with the public discussion about
police reform
it's not happening and yet what's
happening is police are leaving the
police force the people that these
individuals like black lives matter say
that they're trying to help
they're they're dying i mean think about
how many people have been murdered over
the past year alone
uh given the violent you know the
violent crime that's gone up in the city
so it's just
just by you i mean i mean yeah exactly
and you're reckless drunk and rages
the people that you've been stabbing
well there's that you know
it's it's it's scary kt i'm sorry that
you're sitting next to this crazy person
not that close though we have our social
distance yes yes which by the way is
meaningless
social distancing is we are like this is
so stupid do you know that you can
kt you can sit in a restaurant now
across from somebody but we have these
tv shows where we're like six eight feet
apart it's just
absolutely stupid of course but we're in
new york
everything in new york is stupid i'm
coming back from the free state of
florida where people are walking around
like normal human beings yeah isn't it
ironically everybody makes fun of
florida for being abnormal
but they're the most normal which makes
them adorable
wow head-blown
blindingly obvious yes there you go it's
been a long time since i've talked to
you what do you make of this uh uh i
um lisa basically took all the talking
points so like we're left with
there's still more actually i've had
about five more minutes
i could have gone on yes what do you um
what do you make a
of my suggestions i'm you probably don't
aren't going to go far with me on the
drug stuff yeah no i was a little
nervous about that but otherwise
no i think it makes an enormous amount
but particularly your point
that they're trying to distract our
attention right i mean here we are we're
moving to socialism
we're canceling the culture we're taking
an entire a
nation and constitution and flushing it
down the toilet and yet we're supposed
to
worry about things like all the
insensible things that you've talked
about no it's not
debate it's all you know initially they
use the excuse of well donald trump is
so terrible
that the rules no longer apply we're
going to just go after him
but he's gone now yeah but it was the
pandemic well you know because of these
exceptional situation
we now have to take even more control
well you know what that's going on
oh but now we've got to deal with racism
up up there's always an excuse but you
know the end result that their solution
is
big government yeah or also or
driving the voters so deep to
desperation that they have to
elect republicans to clean up the mess
it's like the parent child like we get a
parent
and then we get a child and then we get
a parent we get a child like they're now
looking at some of the what trump did in
immigration
they're echoing it they're gonna have to
start doing that with law well they are
doing with law enforcement now
he was pro law enforcement that
supposedly made him racist
now they're realizing no it's just
sensible so kat
i want to talk about the drug part of
this because i realize that nobody here
on this other side
agrees with me so i understand i
understand
people get mad at me who people have
lost loved ones to drugs
hate the idea a lot of them hate the
idea of legalization but i try to
explain to them that they died
because of the legalization because what
that does is it drives people to take
illicit substances
when if it's controlled and legal you
actually can monetize it monitor it
after it's monetized
absolutely uh and regardless of what
people think you know philosophically
about the war on drugs and whatever your
what your right is or
to put something in your body without
being arrested for it or being jailed
for it
um but we've been doing this for decades
and decades this war on drugs and it's
quite clear that the winner
is drugs like we spent more than a
trillion dollars on this
and there's never been a consistent
stable decline in drug use or abuse
and as you mentioned last year huge
spike in overdoses and the vast majority
of that was with illegal
drugs but yes or because people don't
know what they're taking they
either they're using something and if
they don't know how much is in it they
don't there's fentanyl in it so it's
about
harm reduction um i don't you know smoke
meth not to brag but the reason
the reason for that is not because it's
illegal it's not because it's illegal
um and the people who do that anyway
it's it's not they're not
clearly not stopped by the fact that
it's illegal either yeah you choose your
drug
regardless of whether it's legal or
illegal and as you know michael you're
dressed right now as a drug dealer
if you want some crystal meth i can hook
you up undercover at the high school
yeah i would
say shave the mustache although are you
a chemistry teacher at the local high
school i'm the cool chem teacher
you know this yes
a couple things sir i'm i'm tired of
like the let's reform police talk
at all right i'm completely bored how
about we reform your
your lousy life right like you have
these these kids out doing like where
are the parents how about parental
reform can we discuss
that how about you don't have a kid
running around the streets of chicago
with the gun it's completely judgmental
and i am correct
yes no but it's true it's like you can't
you cannot make
you can't pass judgment on immoral
behavior or just bad behavior anymore
because now that's being construed as
racist but you can say all cops are bad
including minority ones in a minority
majority city like new york city or
chicago yeah
and i think we should do a thing called
a cop for a day lottery
where someone who's mouthing off about
we need to reform the police
okay you just won the cop for a day
lottery yes we're putting you in a
cruiser and you don't get a gun mister
because you're going to be a good cop
it always changes people's minds when
they do the ride-along
they're never the same i'm not allowed
on ride-alongs because i have my own
police uniform
but my stripping days and it's just it
makes them feel really uncomfortable
and i get it i like to sit in the front
seat with them
right officer greg is in the house i'm
right there
i straddle the shotgun that they got
there it's really very difficult awkward
okay up next hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else